bonjour thomas on imagine beaucoup
d'émotion lors de cette cérémonie
d'hommage à stéphanie vont fermer
mais beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup de
monde aussi qui s'étaient rassemblés ici
sur le parvis l'hôtel de ville de
rambouillet plusieurs centaines de
personnes on a même sans doute dépassé
le millier de personnes qui sont donc
venus assister à cette cérémonie qui se
voulait sobre et qui aura duré une
dizaine de minutes d'ailleurs un petit
peu de déception dans les rangs des
participants à ce rassemblement
lorsqu'il a été annoncé que la cérémonie
touché à sa fin il espérait sans doute
un peu davantage faut dire aussi qu'il
ait eu quelques problèmes techniques
problèmes de sons notamment ce qui n'a
pas permis à tout le monde
d'entendre concrètement le discours de
la maire de rambouillet la maire de
rambouillet qui a donc délivré un
message rempli d'émotions la ville de
rambouillet a perdu une part d'elle-même
a notamment déclaré la maire de la ville
il y avait également le président du
sénat gérard larcher ainsi que la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse et puis il y avait
aussi gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur ainsi que marlène schiappa
ministre chargé de la citoyenneté
on a également pu apercevoir la famille
de stéphanie montfermier évidemment
beaucoup d'émotion lors de cette
cérémonie avec des bouquets qui ont été
remis je vous propose d'écouter à des
personnes qui sont venues donc ici pour
assister à cette cérémonie il ya des
habitants de rambouillet mais pas
seulement on a également vu beaucoup de
membres des forces de l'ordre que ce
soit des gendarmes ou des policiers
venir assister à cette cérémonie propose
d'écouter au micro didier migaud
je trouve ça je trouve ça très très
regrettable je veux dire voilà pour le
reste bon on sait dans quelle période
nous vivons on sait qu'elle est là quels
sont les les
les tensions qui existent voilà la ville
de rambouillet répond répond autant
qu'elle peut montre une détermination
par rapport contre le contre le
terrorisme donc voilà je trouve ça très
bien c'était but est une dame très
discrète qui parlait très peu de son
travail qui pourtant était crucial pour
la vie du commissariat puisque j'avais
eu l'occasion de questionner
l'administration sur leur rôle dans le
court 2 de mon stage pour mon rapport de
stage et effectivement je me suis rendu
compte à quel point le rôle a été
crucial dans le dans le commissariat
pour le bon fonctionnement du
commissariat parce qu'il ya toute la
façade enquête mais après bon il faut
quand même sortir les enquêtes et c'est
elle qui permettent le relais entre les
les institutions judiciaires et le
commissaire ya donc c'est vraiment un
rôle qui est très important vous venez
de l'entendre parmi les participants à
ce rassemblement quelques personnes qui
connaissaient la policière qui a été tué
à vendredi c'est donc le cas du jeune
homme que vous venez d'entendre
évidemment tous ici ont voulu apporter
leur soutien à cette famille endeuillée
mais plus généralement aux forces de
l'ordre à la police qui est une fois de
plus la cible d'un attentat terroriste
beaucoup ici nous expliquent qu'ils
attendent désormais des actes de la part
des pouvoirs publics
il y aura un premier élément de réponse
ce sera mercredi le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin va déposer
en conseil des ministres une nouvelle
proposition de loi antiterroriste merci
beaucoup thomas bonnet pour toutes ces
précisions sur cette cérémonie d'hommage
donc et stéphanie et mot fermé